you have this new album
Autumn and I was listening to it today
and it's I what I love is you
orchestrate your music I don't know I
I'm not we call it that too actually
yeah you orchestrate it really uh really
beautifully and you can tell that
there's a lot of
almost like classical thought that goes
into it and no training by the way no
training non-zero
so it's like a it's like a how is that
possible and I understand the the great
story I like to tell is when I was very
young was tested as being gifted in
music you know and uh
they called my father and he was a
musician and said Your son's probably a
musical Savant a seven years old or
something and so a week later they gave
me a piece of paper told me to circle
the instrument that I wanted to play and
then I needed instruction and I went
home and my father saw the cost and
ripped up the paper and threw it in the
garbage and that was the end of my
musical life it up to that point oh wow
so somebody recognized early on that I
had some kind of do you remember what uh
instrument you circled saxophone
maybe your dad did you a favor
I had a I had a I had a oh no he gets
you could be touring with Sade right now
now it gets better it's better I had a
step family
um a German and polish and uh and the
Polish Uncle Uncle Henry
when he found it that I wanted to play
guitar when I was 14 he literally pulled
me aside and said there's no future in
the guitar what you want to play is the
accordion you'll always have a job
and you know when you're having that
conversation like yeah is this real is
he really trying to convince me to play
the accordion and he was dead serious I
think I can top this that with an even
more absurd story which is I get the
Late Night show in uh April of 93 so
it's it's almost it's exactly exactly 30
exactly 30 years since I was they
haven't killed you yet they've tried
they've winged me a few times but uh
almost exactly 30 years ago I get this
job it's announced that the replacement
for David Letterman is going to be this
guy Conan O'Brien everybody's saying who
is this guy what's happening
and I get a call from my uncle
who lives in Worcester Mass who I love
by the way he's a great guy uh Ned and
my uncle Ned calls me and he says what
is this what are you doing I'm reading
in the paper and he said the law you
should study the law he's he was talking
to me about getting into law and trying
to convince me that law was better than
hosting one of only three late night
shows in America and he meant it he
meant back when people actually watched
lately yeah exactly I know so it was uh
but he was saying I'll never forget he
said you can
as a lawyer when you're you can be a
performer in front of a judge but you're
also writing your own scripts when you
prepare a case but you're like
no I am not going to now call NBC and
say this isn't happening I'm going to
imagine that conversation going to law
school they would have said fine we'll
get some other idiot who ran the network
back then uh it was a guy named Bob
Wright ran the network and I think he
actually took a call from my uncle
that's true also is it my uncle also
called Bob Wright and said what do you
do because and it hears the connection
Bob Wright had gone to Holy Cross
College in Worcester and so had my uncle
oh my God so he got through and they
they said Conan's uncle's on the line
and wants to talk to you and so Bob
picked it up and he was like what are
you what are we doing here I mean you
went to the cross I went to the Cross
this is is this the right thing for him
I think the law would be better and he
for years afterwards with Howell telling
that story that's amazing yeah but he
was right I should have done it's so it
almost sounds invented but it's that's
why it's so no no that is a very true
story
um but here's what's amazing to me this
is a uh uh Autumn has
33 songs yes on it and another career
suicide
no I mean I'm not joking it's so you're
I mean you're so prolific and it's but
it's interesting because it's a lot of
artists right now are focusing on these
really small projects and singles and
things like that and you are willfully
saying this is what I'm doing and you're
welcome to join me or not but this is
what I have decided to do yeah without
being political which is hard to do
these days I think the culture is sick
and
counter-intuitive to The Human
Experience and so I've just made a
decision I'm going to do whatever I
think is right
for what I do which is make music and if
people have a problem with it then don't
listen I don't know it's really weird to
me when you sit in boardrooms and people
try to talk a musician into not making
music yeah I mean those are real
conversations I have and I'm like
I don't understand like it's like saying
hey you're really good at juggling don't
juggle so much yeah just to look but why
like I can't I can't wrap my head around
it emotionally or intellectually it
reminds me of when the government is
paying people to destroy crops in order
to stabilize the price yeah that's
that's some of the art they're getting
the kind of scarcity arguments right
like less is more and it's like no how
about I'm gonna be dead soon and I'd
rather leave my kids more songs than
less like let's start there that's my
math right I don't care about your math
anymore in fact your math is usually
wrong